okay some of you remember I got in
trouble years ago for making a comment
about breastfeeding on an airplane when
there was a kid that looked five or six
years old who was being breastfed and I
said I think the kids too old to be
breastfeeding and the lacked of asturias
with me
the leaky boob another group was
absolutely furious with me and sent me
an article saying breastfeeding is okay
all the way up to seven or eight years
old they didn't convince me but
regardless of that I actually am very
big on affirming the ability for women
to breastfeed in public in any place
where they can legally be unfettered and
unimpeded and the big news is that
breastfeeding has now been legally
affirmed in all 50 states and people
might hear that in say wait a second was
breastfeeding illegal in some states
well wasn't illegal but it was not
legally protected in all places where
women are allowed to be Utah and Idaho
have now legally affirmed breastfeeding
meaning it is now abundantly clear
legally speaking at least that in 50
states women can breastfeed in any place
where they are legally allowed to be
this is actually still controversial in
some parts of the United States
how dare women feed children in front of
other humans babies clearly must be fed
in private for some reason I can't
really understand in Utah some of the
Republican opposition feels that
breastfeeding is too in-your-face if
done in a public place Idaho
sort of had an easier time this time
around but in the past has had trouble
with male legislators who were worried
that women would whip it out and do it
anywhere that's a direct quote from some
of the prior debate in Idaho about
public breastfeeding I genuinely don't
get why this is even something we're
still talking about I mean not not only
does this make sense because we
shouldn't be shaming women it also makes
sense because the stigma around
breastfeeding by pushing women into
bathrooms
makes it so that more women don't
necessarily breastfeed when it's been
found that assuming that there aren't
any health risks or particular medical
situations breastfeeding is the best
option for the early nutrition of babies
so there's basically two types of
breastfeeding laws some states say
specifically anyplace women can legally
be they're allowed to breastfeed in
other states the law sort of affirms or
clarifies that female breasts exposed
for breastfeeding purposes are exempt
from public indecency statutes right
there are some places where female
breasts being exposed would violate
public indecency statutes and the way
that breastfeeding is legally affirmed
in those states is that it says that if
you're breastfeeding and your breasts
are out you're you're not liable to be
charged under public indecency statutes
so more than illegal what happens here
is that we can say we are legally
protecting breastfeeding in all 50
states I've actually seen some pretty
big kerfuffle start because of a woman
breastfeeding and I know that people who
live in relatively progressive and and I
guess we would say more enlightened
parts of the United States would be
shocked to hear this but I've seen on
airplanes and I'm not now I'm not even
talking about the incident I referred to
earlier I've seen controversy on
airplanes about women breastfeeding I've
seen it in restaurants I saw it once in
a government building and also in a
hotel lobby people just get upset and
disgusted and they start kind of going
out of their way to look disgusted about
what they're seeing and one I read about
is anger about breastfeeding at swimming
pools where it says no food allowed this
is one of the dumbest opposition's to
public breastfeeding that I've actually
seen and it's more common than you might
imagine
no food allowed at swimming pools is
because of some guy with popcorn or
candy bars where you don't want the
wrappers or kernels of popcorn in the
pool women nursing their kids is not why
those rules exist and even if you don't
nurse I hate to break it to you but the
food is still in the pool area
right the the milk is still there it's
not the eating that you're not supposed
to do it's the halving of the food and
that doesn't change and forget about the
spirit of the rule it's just not why
these rules
forget about the letter of the rule
rather the spirit of those rules is not
about a woman feeding her kid it's the
dude with donuts and the melting
chocolate bar that caused those rules to
be in place and I just think that this
is such a stupid debate to be having and
it it also there's a sort of sidebar
debate that correlates with this a
little bit which is that there are lots
of places where the topless laws are not
gendered in other words both men and
women are allowed to be topless try
walking by as a woman topless and see
how quickly things will esta gate into
escalate with the so-called moral
majority folks but if you are against
public breastfeeding please email me I
want to hear from you because I just
don't get it what what is it exactly
that you're opposed to discuss this or
any other stories from today's show on
today's on the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
IDI di t we will take a quick break I am
in New Orleans Louisiana at Netroots
nation and much more about what's going
on here
coming up later today's program was made
possible in part by Blink asam / pakman
I love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the David
Pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
studs is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books if they condense them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
7-day free trial by going to blink East
calm / Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up